safer sex kids herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video ich sitze ja gerade es
841 an einem freitagabend und ich habe
mir gerade ein video von denen
angeschaut und bin darunter in die
kommentare gegangen und habe ein
bisschen gestöbert und ohne wird sicher
muss darüber ein video machen was da los
ist alter unfassbar schaut sich einfach
selbst an fällt aber die kommentare
vorlesen die lustigsten raussuchen
einfach mal drauf reagieren also aus
trophäe wird hier trophy profi
hundefutter
und er macht der ddr einfach mal 198
millionen autos in einer nacht mit ina
zensiert herzlichen glückwunsch zum 200
millionen alles okay und dann hier unten
noch ja diese dummheit ist nicht
auszuhalten kann man so sehen
mit der neuheit wird ich wollte sagen
die sind nicht dumm wechsel wächst die
von wem redet er da und den als beste
eigenwerbung
schaut mal auf meinem kanal hat ihn
machen das mal so auf hier schaut mal
auf meinem kanal zeigt sei vorbei dafür
dass er ein anfänger ist ist er schon
gut macht allein hdf hast wirst du sie
höchst
weil eigenwerbung auf youtube weiblich
existent ist was gibt's ja gar nicht er
macht einfach serbe für die kanal ja nie
wissen was das bedeutet sagt jessica i o
das ist so geil
ohne witz das ist einfach witzig ist es
auch gar nicht wissen weil das ist
scheiße lustig was auf 100 euro perle
spiel spielelandschaft nein das ist
nicht landschaft und dann nahm sich
kraft die schwimmer landschaft bei 350
loszuziehen
nach hinten ab los los spiellandschaft
spuhler
was könnte landschaft simulator sein
schreibt in die kommentare
mannschaft alter mittelost experte los
genau jetzt
das wäre echt cool es geht einfach immer
weiter die leute werden nicht wieder so
geile kommentare jetzt schreibt okay
hier das video war so krass dass ich
jetzt gesagt ein red bull druck es war
aber abgesehen davon dass diese gibt
dieser kommentar auf seiner nicht allzu
großen wort zahl mit rechtschreibfehlern
durchsetzt ist er strotzt nur so vor
rechtschreibfehlern verstehe ich einfach
die aussage nicht also das video hat
sich einfach wieder ruhe gedanken worte
[ __ ] sitzt er da so bull dosen und ein
video krass ist dann auf einmal boa und
er ganz gar nicht kontrollieren alles
klar ich hab einfach nur getrunken wie
die häuser christ wann machst du mal
wieder was mit easy bienen oder david
copperfield also ich jetzt mal
hingeschaut habe bei dem video das am
leben
dieses eben darin auf einmal lag mit 2
millionen autos wieso bist du immer
meistens üblich dass ein
du bist hässlich
also man kann wahrscheinlich viele
sachen über den eher sagen aber
sicherlich nicht der selbst die tube und
vor allem nicht ist also ganz ehrlich
schaut überhaupt seine videos ok in der
kontur schau dich an
sorry bei antwortet direkt sorry bei tut
mir leid denn also das möchte ich gerne
erklärt haben diese leute schreiben die
übelsten beleidigungen in die kommentare
seit einer so er das nicht cool studium
immer halt alles wusste weiß ich nicht
ich wusste nicht dass du bist hässlich
und fett eine beleidigung ist und es tut
mir so leid
erhalte hier
du hast die treffe nicht nicht nicht nie
sollte man ihn du hast die treffen mich
nicht vom letzten trophy jeder mensch
der auch dass deutschland mit verlassen
mächtiges geht bei sowas einfach
ausschlag also leute ganz ehrlich lasst
uns mal ein wettbewerb machen
ich möchte gerne von euch wissen welche
version des wortes trophäe oder trophy
in diesem video euch am besten gefallen
hat hier haben wir zum abschluss nochmal
eine und zwar recht doch in der nächsten
folge in paletten basis ein und klauen
die trophäe zum abschluss leute das ist
natürlich von meiner seite nicht böse
gemeint sondern einfach nur ein job wie
helga bock darauf dass zu machen und
deswegen gibt es das jetzt auf meinem
kanal ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen
lassen like da lange für 80 und